[Musique]
il est de retour pour ses résultats
sportifs du week-end michael et demi
d'euro bonds soir sans grégory
l'actualité sportive encore une fois
chargé on va commencer cette chronique
en prenant notre respiration est ce que
vous avez déjà vu une performance à
couper le souffle
bah écoutez vous allez nous en parler
voilà c'était le cas ce dimanche au
centre aquatique de saint cyr l'école le
franco cuba andy cabreira avila que vous
voyez à l'image avec son aileron de
dauphin a réalisé un nouveau record
après avoir nagé en apnée dynamique
pendant six heures et 12 heures ces
dernières années cette fois ci il ne
respirait que 4 minutes et 12 secondes
pendant six heures d'apnée statique
c'est énorme
un défi qu'il s'est lancé pour dénoncer
la maltraitance des animaux marins dans
les parcs aquatiques
on écoute la réaction de ce champion
juste à la sortie de son record il ya
beaucoup de choses qui avoue j'avais
voulu à côté c'est nos stops ou sur la
spli c'est difficilement cette hauteur
d'avoir fini j'ai pas aux grandes
capacités pulmonaires donc j'ai joué ma
force de volonté mais ces dégâts d'un
bon mental j'ai dépensé à como france
les nageurs espère également voir réussi
son autre défi sensibiliser le grand
public sur la cause animale
on parle maintenant en baseball michael
direction montigny le bretonneux oui il
rit je vois que vous suivez bien
l'actualité sportive du département les
cougars de montigny le bretonneux
finaliste malheureux la saison passée de
première division repartent au combat
pour aller chercher leur graal et ils
ont plutôt bien réussi leurs débuts ce
dimanche ils se sont imposés 9 0 et 9 à
2 sont les deux matchs contre les
cavigal de nice lors de la première
journée du championnat
quelles sont les attentes des supporters
nous sommes allés à leur rencontre qui
et remporte le championnat
et qui retourne en finale l'année
dernière phrase est en finale si j'ai
pas de bêtises donc qui retourne en
finale et qui gagne qui gagnent la coupe
d'europe à brno mois de juin ça serait
super
en championnat qui gardent leur place en
finale ce serait comme l'année dernière
ça serait super après peut-être battre
ans c'est possible voilà débat victoire
simplement voilà bah oui déjà ce serait
pas mal je suis très optimiste pour la
saison à venir il ya une très bonne
cohésion goût et je pense que le travail
de cet hiver va payer on ira encore plus
loin cette année nous sommes en national
et puis aussi d'europe ça les supporters
vont-ils et être satisfait de lait des
performances de leurs protégés réponse
dans quelques mois à gré est interdite
par le résultat de rugby mutuelle alors
on termine donc ce tour d'horizon par
une note très positive le rugby-club de
versailles fêté ce week-end la montée en
fédérale 3 devant des centaines de
supporters dans une ambiance électrique
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
et les joueurs l'ont fait plaisir en
l'emportant 37 à 12 soit ça clichy leur
16e victoire en 16 matches disputés et
tenteront maintenant de remporter le
championnat de france pour que la fête
soit encore plus belle
merci michael ses résultats bien
d'autres encore dans votre émission le
7-8 sport a retrouvé dans un instant
après ce journal